- [Instructor] After
practicing the violin together
for 15 years, Justine told Katie
that she was the better violinist.
Alright, so immediately when I read that
when they say that she
was the better violinist,
I don't know, is Justine
talking about she Justine
or is Justine talking about she Katie?
So this pronoun she,
who is it referring to?
Is it referring to Katie or
is it referring to Justine?
It could be either one.
Justine could be saying
that Justine is better
or she could be saying
that Katie is better.
The way it's written, you do not know
which kind of makes the
sentence fairly meaningless
so I definitely don't wanna
keep it the way it is.
So what I would want is some clarity
on who was the better violinist.
So what I like about this second choice
is it makes it very clear
that Katie was the better violinist.
Let's read that.
After practicing the violin
together for 15 years,
Justine told Katie that Katie
was the better violinist.
Yep, I definitely like it.
Now you might say oh look,
I'm using the Katie twice
in three words in the sentence.
Isn't that redundant?
And it might feel that
way but you really do
need to use Katie twice
in order to make sure
that you understand that Justine thinks
that Katie was the better violinist.
So this needs to be Katie right over here.
If you don't do that,
you don't know who
Justine is talking about.
And then the other choices, let's see.
After practicing the violin
together for 15 years,
Justine told Katie that
she's was the best, better.
Well this one is just,
this one is ambiguous,
this one's just grammatically incorrect.
You're having a possessive pronoun here,
what are you possessing?
So definitely rule that one out and then
after practicing the violin
together for 15 years,
Justine told Katie that they
were the better violinist.
Well they were, that's not making sense.
It's saying that they were both
but it's making a comparison
to whom, I don't know.
They could say Justine
told Katie that they were
both good violinists, that would
have been an okay statement
but that's not what they're saying.
They were making a comparison
on who is a better violinist,
so this doesn't make sense either.